we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
uh
we um i this is kind of a funny
voicemail i got my radical trumpists
confused on i guess
yesterday we were talking about people
associated with trumpism who were
running in 2022 and i got my trumpists
confused listen to this
hi david just watching your show and i
wanted to make a
small correction uh j.r majewski isn't
from michigan he's from ohio's ninth
congressional district and the other guy
that you interviewed from michigan was
john gibbs
i'm sure they all just kind of run
together after a while yeah just wanted
to let you know thank you bye yeah
that's actually exactly what happened i
was kind of just going from memory about
various trumpets we've interviewed and
spoken to and whatever i got the states
wrong so i apologize they're they're all
still radical nuts
but i did get the states wrong and for
that i apologize because we want
accuracy
and precision both on this program we
have a great bonus show for you today we
are going to talk about what's happening
in the elections in the philippines it
is absolutely fascinating and i think it
will be of interest to many in our
audience we are going to talk about the
new biden administration proposal to cap
the cost of the internet
for low-income americans of internet
service to be clear and it seems natural
that we would do this and yet there are
many people that are completely furious
about it so we're going to talk about
that and we are also going to talk more
about abortion rights activists
demonstrating outside the homes
of supreme court justices we have some
opinions about whether that's okay to do
or not we are going to get more opinions
about that producer pat will join me
we're going to talk about ambush
journalism protesting at people's houses
all these types of things uh and there
really are very different views about if
and when if ever
and when these tactics are okay to use
all of those stories and more are on
today's bonus show we do a bonus show
every day for our members you can sign
up and become a member at joinpacman.com
and you can use the coupon code obama to
uh become a member that's obama
and just remember alex jones hates the
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad so
just as long as you're comfortable
supporting something alex jones hates
sign up at jointpakman.com and i will
see you then